gelbe es bricht uns allen das arug das
ist instabil leiste hallo ich meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einem video wo ich lege minecraft
spiegelmere wird das jetzt zugesendet
und ich habe mir gedacht kommen ich
spiele es einfach mal nicht weil letzten
schon mal im supermarkt und hab ein
bettgitter gefragt hey wo finde ich
eigentlich lege mein körper das war da
noch gar nicht das gesuchte und jetzt
hab ich gesehen ist das war schon andere
youtuber markt wie beispielsweise simon
also auf ungefilterte das glaube ich mal
und noch ein paar andere also das soll
jetzt nicht nachmachen sein oder so
sondern ich bin einfach auch ein kleines
kind was früher mit lego gespielt hat
oder einfach bock auf die pflege
minecraft und habe jetzt einfach ein
bisschen zusammen gespielt die sache ist
ich habe zwei sets einmal die farm und
einmal die sandler mit ender drach und
sorgt und in diesem video mache ich
jetzt die erste tüte fertig von der farm
bei der farben waren drei tüten dabei um
das erste 1 fertigbauen an tüte 200-300
was will man das ganze in die zusammen
das heißt dieses farben dings punkt
mache ich dann in drei parts und in
diesem video jetzt was auch schon
relativ lange es baue ich nur die erste
tüte zusammen das heißt wenn ihr eine
zweiten part wollt wo ich habe zwei
zusammenbauen einen dritten paar in
zweiter dann streift er reicht mir das
in den kommentare was ich besser machen
könnte von der kamera oder sonst
irgendwas und was irgendwie zeigt es mir
mit einem daumen hoch wenn jetzt vor
seiten die kommentare zu schreiben und
so weiter erinnern will ich da anfangen
jetzt auch schon am mit dem bau so
freundin auf dem jetzt dieses anfangs
geplapper da von mir gehört habt zeige
ich euch jetzt erstmal was mir beim
zugesendet hat und zwar einerseits ein
paket was noch da hinten darum steht was
ihr allerdings gab ich sehe das ist
dieses mit im ende und somit dem ende
drachen und so und die haben wir das
zugesendet ich glaube das heißt
verstehen so ein paar sachen drin wie
man das ganze dauert ich hoffe die
kamera einstellung passt sollte das
ganze irgendwie von oben film aber ich
habe das gar nicht so gemacht bzw
ich glaube ich ändern die ganze
perspektive mal einfach weil er dass er
so gar nicht richtig sehen können da
habe ich jetzt auch schon die
perspektive geändert hallo ich sehe
ich habe jetzt hier dieses pack team wie
schon gesagt vor mir liegen wo ein paar
sachen drin sind und ich werde einfach
jetzt mal ein bisschen was zusammenbaut
ich habe mir gedacht das kannst dich auf
einem gaming an anrufe weil das ganze
mehr oder weniger gaming es ist
minecraft und so weiter und so fort ich
habe hier erstmal diese grundplatte die
darmstädter oder seht ihr meine softbox
und mein fenster wo also habe ich gerne
diese grundplatte deutsche nummer eins
und das ist erst als erste tüte die uns
interessiert weil es bei lego ist es so
das kenne ich noch es gibt immer
verschiedene typen dringlicher
verschiedene teilbereich von damals man
muss erstmal tüte ein zusammenbauen
danach bietet 2 1 83
und dann sollte das ganze am ende
irgendwann etwas geben das richtig cool
in wie das lego sowas gemacht hat ich
baue jetzt erstmals tief zusammen ohne
dass ich hier in der anleitung überhaupt
am start habe
der kopfballtreffer
jaja fokussiert sich um eine fuchs doch
teil seiner daher ist der krieg geil ich
freue mich gerade wie so ein kleines
kind wegen den ganzen sachen hier an
krebs ich mich aber echt frage ist
einfach wohnt dieser stock von ist dass
die pro es kann ja überhaupt alles was
ich euch hier zeige guck mal ist dass
ein brot ich weiß gar nicht wer selbst
ein bisschen komisch jetzt film falls
irgendwelche tipps habt wie immer unten
in den kommentaren platz hat für dich
doch das tier soll eine kiste darstellen
scheiß auf die auf die komische
anleitung die da mit bye ist ich brauche
das einfach mal selber alles zusammen ja
ich glaube das ist eine kiste von mir
sonne es trotz immer weine aspekt im
büro ein dann müssen wir das hier am
ende müssen wir daraus kriegen lief und
einen krieg und ein schwert müssen dass
schwerreiche und es erschwert und ich
glaube hier ist auch nie das crafting
table
diese ganzen kleinen kleinen shuccle
aber irgendwie den kopf von schießt geld
wieder liegt irgendwo auf dem teppich
nicht bewusst denn der kopf von steve
wahrscheinlich habt ihr schon überhaupt
so in dem video schon direkt gesehen und
ich mir wieder zu blöd teams befinden
hier und jetzt baue ich ihnen darauf
diesen kopf von steve und dann haben wir
eine kleine spielfiguren wie knuffig ist
ist einfach so kleider europe okay ist
die von den keeper haben wir schon mal
was wir als nichts machen müssen
angeblich soll es tief in die hand einer
axt oder ein schwert bekommen das heißt
ich schaue jetzt mal hier ebenso viele
irgendwo und ein schwert den sc schon
gleich fällt irgendetwas von diesem
tisch hier runter dann musste es wieder
vom boden aufheben und so weiter und
hier haben wir die axt und wir haben das
schwert ihren das ist echt ein bisschen
blöd mit diesem auto fokus das ja immer
so ein bisschen länger brauchen das
ganze an zu fokussiert aber wir haben
das schwert wir haben hier den den den
axt limit erst mal ganz kurz die aktuell
ist es schwert und packt er's tiefen
jahren weil ihr wisst ja ich bin so der
schwerter aber ich überhaupt hier könnt
wenig angreifer ich bin dann greift er
den krippen und tormann ich fühle mich
echt wie so ein kleines kind aber ich
weiß nicht ich war auch immer mehr der
lego schubert der playmobil gibt es auch
verschiedene meinungen
playmobil ist wer diese der beim krieger
haben wir noch zwei sachen gefiel guck
mal beim klipper müssten an den rahmen
doch da jeweils eine platte und da eine
platte und dann hat man es lieber ich
habe ja schon gefragt warum wir hier
einmal am rand so komische kleine blöde
pünktchen hat und jetzt hat der körper
hier auch am rand so ein bisschen hier
so ein plättchen und daran hat er nicht
so komische blöde pünktchen das heißt
steve ist fertig und der keeper ist
fertig die seht ihr hier schon am rand
aufgebaut
ich schau mal was wir als nächstes
machen müssen
okay wir müssen jetzt zwei platten
miteinander verbinden ich lege die
zeitschrift mal so hier hin dass ihr ihn
natürlich nicht sehen können richtig gut
dafür benötige ich zweimal den kleinen
block hier und ein mal sondern etwas
länglichen den ländlicheren mag ich hier
dran um die beiden sachen miteinander zu
verbinden
die kommt am rand muss so ein kleiner
karg stiftung und am letzten schwerer
der seite weiter ich zeige euch das mal
wieder plätze die sind nicht gerade
schon hier für diesen teil benötigen die
große grüne platte zwei lange
scheißhaufen und zwei kleine
scheißhaufen ich brauche es menschen
zusammenbringt hat mir das nicht direkt
lego zugesendet sondern sondern ging so
ein typ von plan.net teilweise nicht
genau
igor hieß der mit dem süßen kleinen
brief so beschrieben so trifft auf
contra voll cool weiß wie ich ganz cool
ich wollte mir dass er sogar im laden
kaufe ich hab getwittert hey das lego
minecraft schon draußen statt im
supermarkt und wollte das kaufen gab es
aber noch nicht und jetzt habe ich ihn
zugesendet bekommen die ich extrem cool
also ich bekomme nichts dafür dass das
spiel ich mache das einfach nur spaß er
hat nicht mal gesagt dass ich unbedingt
aufnehmen wollen wir nur einen gefallen
tun und das finde ich sehr sehr liebt
dass es die leute doch gibt die nicht so
gemerkt drauf sind und jetzt nehme ich
dir diesen einsätzen ich habe mich
wahrscheinlich schon irgendwo verbaut
und jeder schlägt sich gar die hände
überm kopf zu tragen so und jetzt sieht
das ganze so von unten aus und so von
oben und ich denke hier kommt an dem wir
die farmen also ich hab diesen karton
weggeschmissen wie es am ende aussehen
soll aber alle was ich kann sich eben
zeigen das ganze soll am ende aussehen
ich weiß nicht ob ich das schon am
anfang gezeigt habe aber das wird dann
wahrscheinlich echt einfach dieser
untergrund sein ich werde jetzt hier in
der ersten folge den untergrund bauen
danach kommt dann
die anderen sachen also tüte bei und
führte 3 kommt dann immer zwei und drei
im buch schnell dass ihr mich auch mal
wieder sehen
halo spiel lego hoch jetzt nehme ich mir
hier wieder ein paar von setzt sich hier
einen hin
dann kommt hier noch ein wenig auf das
grüne auf das gelbe kohlen das ist
instabil scheiße das wird auch nur von
diesem paar blättchen hier zusammen
gehalten man das war immer mein problem
bei lego das ist irgendwie nach derzeit
die nachhaltigkeit also ein bisschen
nicht gewährleistet das ist so wie mit
dem berliner flughafen ist dann
irgendwann fertig und es ist eine
dauerbaustelle oder irgendwie sollen
damit nach der bürgermeister tritt an
zurück und das bin ich manchmal nicht
erkennen wenn ich mal in vielen
wahrscheinlich schon abgeschaltet weil
das die nicht interessiert es macht mir
spaß und deswegen werde ich das auf
jeden fall noch dieses liegen auf jeden
fall weiter bauen ich habe auch noch das
end am start und könnte damit den
entsprechend ich weiß nicht wie viele
typen am end dabei sind bestimmt fünf
oder so oder so viel größeres halt mehr
so mit klein krams wird mir schon oft
bei mendes gar nicht so viel kleinkram
es das ganze so riesige türme gebaut
okay der ender drachen den
zusammenzubauen denke ich guck die ganze
nacht da vorne weil da mein nv verstehen
aber hallo hier kommen noch von glocken
dann kommt hier noch einer handy vorne
kommt jetzt dieses komische kleine ding
hin sagt mir zumindest meine anleitung
kommt hier einloggen
hier ein ohr ein spricht schon wieder
auseinander alternative dieser kleine
block in der mitte ist echt ein bisschen
der in stabilitätsfaktor dieses projekt
ziehe also so weit sind sie jetzt ihr
könnt ja schon mal ganz kurz ein
bisschen angucken ich schaue eben die
lange überhaupt das noch ist das ist ich
habe die hälfte fällig glaube ich von
von tüte ein also ich habe im training
nur die die uhr läuft schon seit zwölf
minuten also wahrscheinlich das video
wäre das ein bisschen bearbeiten das ist
danach nicht solange es trotzdem krass
wie viel das ist tatsächlich gleich
wieder jetzt jetzt kommt cooler
mechanismus man hat dieses ding hier so
man ich mach mal ganz kurz ihr dass ihr
das wieder seht dass ich ihren klein
bisschen den hintergrund erzeugt
man hat dieses ding um einer dieses ding
und die muss man jetzt ineinander
stecken und dann hat man so eine
schiebetür und dann kommen noch drei von
so kleinen sachen hängen ich denke das
ist eigentlich egal wo ich die hinsetze
also ich hab mir das jetzt ganz so ein
bisschen auf das genau nach anleitung
mache aber ich denke da kommt einfach
nachher so ein paar pflänzchen rein
das brot kommt übrigens doch in diese
kiste also die kiste habe ich ja schon
zusammen gebaut und das brot habe ich
mich gepackt um das dann nicht einfach
aber die kiste soll offen bleiben mit
dem brot und das soll dann
wahrscheinlich am ende irgendwann so
aussehen so sieht das dann aus mit der
kiste ich kann die nicht zu machen das
boot ist so groß für diese stimme von
mike passt nur ein bote der crystal wie
traurig wird also oder als die kiste am
start und jetzt kommt der crafting cable
dafür musste ich das so zusammen bauen
jetzt brauche ich den zweiten stein
sollte sieht nämlich genauso aus und
jetzt nehme ich das eine was hier vorhin
drin war von dem crafting table setzte
dass der wolf fast börse kräftig genug
sind einfach mal hier so mitten in den
raum rein dann haben wir noch ein
crafting table drin rein theoretisch
kann man das ganze aufbauen wie man
möchte ich meine minecraft mehr oder
weniger
mal wieder eine seite weiter mal kurz
zum update wir sind auf seite 12 ich
zeig euch das mal ganz kurz
gerade am start und das ganze geht bis
seite 18 also nicht mehr wohl aber dann
kommen bietet zwei kommt anderen staaten
wird das ausgebaut das kommt ein paar
zwei wenn ihr genügend leicht oder so
habe dass ihr das überhaupt feiert jetzt
nicht irgendwie macht soundsoviele like
some staaten quatsch ich möchte nur dass
er mir das durch die level oder durch
kommentare das regal zu kommen dafür
nichts war nur dass er zeigt das gefällt
uns oder acht das gefällt uns nicht
jetzt mal eine andere taktik vor dass
ich etwas eine fertig machen und die
dann zusammen und jetzt sind wir auch
schon mit den gelben sachen denke ich
erst mal hinter uns obendrauf kommen
jetzt auch noch welche zu stabilität
also hier kommt eine hammer kommen
dunkelgrauer hin wie kommt auch ein
dunkelgrauer hin und hier kommen diese
teile in jetzt kommen die länglichen
hier noch an rand ich weiß echt gerade
nicht was ich hier jetzt überhaupt ein
aspekt gerade bauen
das soll nachher hier die die küche
werden ach so hier oben kommt ein
längliches dinge dann kommt ein
längliches ding ein ekliger hahahahaha
wir machen so wenn ich lache ich sie
komisch dass ihr keine face com am start
wahrscheinlich werde ich das das nächste
mal ein bisschen anders aufnehmen und
dann auch noch mal mein gesicht
aufnehmen mit meiner web kann man das
ganze dann auf meinem schreibtisch
spielen das immer ein gesicht dabei seht
dass ich das ein bisschen so holdco mit
theo koll ist aber echt schwer jetzt
muss ich aber echt ein paar sachen nicht
mal eben hier organisieren wie ich dass
wir zusammen baue ich mache einfach ein
ganz kurzen hat und eben hier diese
ganze kleinen chance ihr zusammen wie
beispielsweise hier so einen ofen oder
hier noch ein paar kleine sachen und
merke ich dann gleich wieder wenn das
fertig so ich habe die teile jetzt
fertig gebaut und zwar sollen das hier
denke ich irgendwelche löcher einfach
darstellen so hier wo einfach so eine
platte drauf ist oder kleine am
kronenweg wir halten diese platten im
mai kräftig hat gar nicht so sicher
einfach displays oder irgendwie wunder
das bringe ich jetzt hier einfach mal an
dann habe ich hier auch so einen kleinen
ofen noch gebaut den seht ihr der sieht
so aus und was ich
auch gebaut hat ist so eine kleine blume
die blume kommt einfach mal hier drauf
also zumindest habe ihr das auch in der
anleitung so weit sind wir gerade meine
lieben freunde also das ist das eine
was wir jetzt gerade gemacht haben und
was wir vorher gemacht haben sieht so
aus ich hab immer dieser horror vision
muss ich ehrlich sagen diese horror
vision bei lego dass ich irgend einen
kleinen block verlieren der fehlten am
ende das ist immer das was ich da dabei
ist in minecraft aufgestellte kommt dann
hole ich mir halt neuen blog jetzt eben
wieder in lego ist das natürlich und da
kann man sich nicht mal eben sondern
block holen oder kann man sich
mittlerweile schon neue block gegenüber
lego online bestellen da übrigens hier
jetzt gerade sondern unseren kleinen
tisch noch in die ecke gepflanzt ein
kleines update hier da ist noch ein
kleiner tipp stock einmal die planen
berlin findet jemand hätten und jetzt
wird das bett gebaut freunde das bett
ist denke ich jetzt mittlerweile echt so
das konstrukt was die meisten
teilschritte benötigt und zwar fünf teil
schritt um dieses bett fertig zu bauen
und fertig ist und wir kennen natürlich
direkt neben dem oa oder weil die
eurovision das ding kohl hat einfach weg
kennen natürlich direkt neben dem tisch
so sieht das ganze gerade aus ich zeig
euch das nach einem extrem fertig ist
das bett ist noch gar nicht richtig
trauma okay jetzt der moment gekommen wo
ich das ganze jetzt zusammenbau und zwar
nehme ich jetzt das hier setze das hier
dran jetzt kann ich das aufklappen wenn
ich damit so irgendwie spielen möchte
jetzt kann ich so machen würde ich das
auto klopft auch vom bag gelaunt hält
sogar johann ok tatsache ist jetzt
allerdings mir fehlen einige sachen bzw
ich habe hier noch ein paar sachen übrig
aber die sind hier noch gar nicht
wirklich eingebaut also die axt ist okay
gar nicht sagen ist ein zweiter
gegenstand dem packen jetzt erst mal
hier in die kiste noch rein wo natürlich
extrem viel platz helmut in eine kiste
passt ein boot und eine achse lee also
hier der kleine steve ist fertig dann
lief steht hier in seinem haus und der
kripo läuft irgendwo draußen herum der
steht hier natürlich draußen weil da
kommt natürlich nicht ins häuschen rein
ich hab so ein paar blöcke übrig sagt
genug ist ein paar lego steine übrig ich
denke dass es wirklich so gewollt wenn
ich das verliere ich packte jetzt aber
mal einfach hier überall so ein bisschen
drauf hier so als beleuchtung sage ich
jetzt mal so ich bin mir
weniger fällig also ich muss jetzt ich
habe natürlich auf 25 übrig ich hab hier
noch diese zwei und führte 3 am staaten
länder zufolge zweiten folge drei
freunde folge sache die kamera dann
einfach aufgehört aufzunehmen ich weiß
nicht wann genau das passiert ist ich
denke erst relativ spät ich bin auf
jeden fall jetzt fertig mit dem aufbauen
und zeigt euch das ganze jetzt einfach
mal so sieht das hier aus wenn ich hier
mal jetzt einfach schaue hier ist der
keeper am start steht draußen ich hatte
hier so ein paar blöcke übrig ich weiß
nicht ob ich das ganze hier jetzt das
noch aufgenommen wurde und zwar habe ich
hier beispielsweise noch einen gelben
block übrig hier noch so einen orangen
fälle übrig dann hier noch sonnengelbe
suche ich das ganze hier aus hier ist
dieser coole mechanismus dass man das
ganze auf machen kann und also das ist
denke ich würde es für das ende auf
jeden fall besser weil ich habe ja wie
ich schon gesagt habe ich jedoch zwei
tüten übrig wo dann noch hier das haus
ein bisschen in die höhe gebaut wir
allerdings sieht das ganze so erstmal
aus also hier draußen steht der kripo
herum der denkst ich musste steve läuft
hier so rohe mir irgendwie und da ist
tief am start und er steht in dem lego
dingsbums hier drin mit seinem schwert
und alles möglich ist der kräftige table
das bett und die kiste und alles
mögliche und m
ich würde sagen freunde ich hoffe euch
hat dieses video von lego minecraft
gefallen nicht sitzt bei mir auf dem
sofa was man eventuell aus ein paar
bildern kenne es euch gefallen hat habe
ich ja schon ganz oft gesagt zeigt mit
einer bewertung ob ihr noch wollt dass
ich tüte 2 und hüte 3 auch noch ausbauen
daraus eine serie mehr oder weniger
mache also ich hab dann nachher noch
ändern
das ende mit dem ende brachte und so und
ich würde einfach sagen dann war's das
von diesem video und wir sehen uns in
einem anderen video wieder zu